hey what's up my name is samuel lees i'm
a property investor and in this video
i want to talk about the second lockdown
the national
lockdown that's going to come into place
on thursday
the 4th of november for at least a month
potentially more
how does it affect property investors am
i pleased about it am i really angry
about it
should you be pleased about it well the
first thing i want to say is this jim
rohn says
it's not the wind the blowing of the
wind
that determines the destination it's the
setting of the sail
the same wind blows on us all but it's
the setting of the sail
that determines the destination of where
you'll be
in the exact same way as entrepreneurs
we can't be blown by the wind we can't
say oh it's the second lockdown in that
case
we're just gonna stay in our houses and
we're just gonna wait i'm not gonna do
anything
you have to see the opportunity grant
cardone says never miss
a crisis we are in a crisis we are in a
pandemic
there is a lot of crazy stuff going on
i'm not in this video
here to talk about what i think my
personal opinion
of the lockdown of what i think about
covid19 you know why
because number one i'm not an expert in
kobit 19
i'm an expert in property and number two
is because it doesn't matter what i
think what i think doesn't care my
opinion doesn't matter even my wife
doesn't care about my opinion
so i don't expect you to care about my
opinion i don't expect you to listen to
what i think
about covid19 or about my opinion about
the lockdown but here's what i'm going
to tell you right now in this video i'm
going to tell you
how it affects you as a property
investor
how it's affecting me why am i in my
seat right now why am i shooting a bit i
tell you why because i'm getting ready
to do some viewings
okay right now i'm picking up the phone
all day and guess what
you can still do viewings during the
national
lockdown okay that's good news by the
way
it's not like they're locked down in
april they're keeping
the construction industry open
now when you do viewings you can only go
one at a time
when you do viewings they're going to
encourage you to do a zoom viewing first
but you can still view houses here's why
that's great because
you can still buy properties the
property investment world is still open
it's not closed and i see so many
property investors online
on the facebook groups on the forums
acting like it's closed
acting like you know those people that
are acting like it's close they're like
oh november's are right off
you know oh december christmas it's
right off the same
losers that say 2020 has been a
write-off
while 2020 has been a write-off me and
my students and my team in my world
we've been doing a lot of deals
making good money in property here's the
thing we create our own economy
you can't let boris johnson control your
economy and the economy is not your
economy so
first thing i want to say is this you
can still view houses second thing is
if you're doing brr you're buying
properties to fix them flip them we
finance them
construction work can still continue
builders are still working this is not
like the april lockdown
builders are still doing things there's
what happened in april
was they they put us in complete
lockdown you weren't allowed to go to
school
you weren't allowed to view houses
surveyors couldn't go and
value houses valuers couldn't go and
value houses
which meant that lenders couldn't lend
and if lenders can't lend if mortgage if
mortgages aren't being lent out you
can't buy houses so everything was
paused
and over half a million properties the
the pr
the sales were paused and that caused
houses to drop a little bit
and now boris johnson and the government
are saying we don't want house prices to
keep dropping we don't want that
so they brought in incentives like stamp
duty holidays still open until march
2021
they started giving bounce back loans
they they started incentivizing and what
happened is the property market started
going back up
then boris johnson starts talking about
a five percent a five percent deposit
where first time buyers can borrow 95
percent what's happening is house prices
are going up so even in this recession
as a recession is happening
house prices are going up here's what
the lock down is going to happen with
the second lockdown
there's going to be more bigger
recession as a result of this so shame
it is what it is the same wind blows on
us all more people are going to lose
their jobs there's already been over a
million people in the uk lose their jobs
as a result of this pandemic more people
will lose their jobs
recession leads to the three d's death
people don't die more people are dying
more
whether you whether it's because of code
or not is a whole other story but people
are dying
next is default default payments and
divorce
default payments divorce death is going
up it's happening a lot so what's
happening is there are people that are
motivated sellers so even though house
prices are going up
there are motivated sellers around there
are motivated sellers
but most of the buyers most amateur
investors
are saying oh it's non-essential it
might be non-essential for you but guess
what for me this is essential
for me i need i i need to feed my kids
and i'm doing that via property
so i'm still viewing houses i'm still
doing deals there are motivated sellers
out there so this video is really a
message to just say
wake up and stop thinking that you have
to stay in your house and you can't view
houses you can't do deals you can
i did three deals property deals
today monday today monday i've done
three property deals
i'm ringing up agents today and i'm
booking
viewings for next week and throughout
the back end of this week
so even thursday friday and i'm speaking
to ages and they're letting me know some
agents are funny about it
some agents will say they can't but some
will say they can so
while there's a problem there's a bigger
opportunity while the people are making
excuses
great let them make excuses so listen if
you're one of those people that say
you know it's not essential i'm just
going to stay home i'm not going to view
houses that's fine
you do that me my team my students
we're going to be making money this
month we're going to be viewing houses
we're going to be securing lease option
agreements we're going to be securing
brr deals
it's happening so second lockdown is it
good or is it bad for investors
depends on the kind of investor you are
i actually think it's gonna be a good
thing for me
i'm excited i'm pumped let me know what
you think in the comments below comment
below
and sorry this video was just a little
bit bang bang bang it's just because i'm
so pumped
i'm so excited and for me whilst i'm
upset
that there's going to be a bigger
recession i know that's going to happen
i am upset about that you cannot control
the economy you can only control your
economy so comment below what you think
if you're still going to be viewing
houses comment below and always always
vagueness as well you know is it
essential though well look
we were told that we can still view
houses he's not closed the housing
market
we've been told that construction is
staying open not like last time when it
closed
the schools are still open education's
still open my education is still open
i'm still teaching every single day
i'm teaching i'm viewing houses i'm
doing deals i think it's actually a good
thing i'm happy i'm glad
comment your thoughts below second
lockdown boom
let's do this let's make november the
best month of the friggin year 2020
i'll be damned if i hear people say 2020
is the right off yeah it's been a good
year and it's gonna end well comment
your thoughts below